good morning uh welcome everybody to
sunrise hospital and medical center my
name is todd slamberg i'm ceo
here at sunrise hospital and medical
center and
on behalf of our entire staff
as well as the united states department
of health and human services
office of the assistant secretary
for preparedness and response or asper
the federal emergency management agency
the state of nevada particularly the
team
of department of health and human
services
public preparedness program and the
staff
at the state board of pharmacy as well
as our colleagues at the southern nevada
health district and i'd like to
introduce and acknowledge dr
michael johnson who's director of
community health
as well as we also have jeff quinn who's
been very instrumental
from the office of public health
preparedness
we're all honored today that you joined
us for this very
very special multi-agency partnership
announcement
the opening of a temporary monoclonal
antibody infusion center for covet 19
patients here in las vegas
joining me today is also dr
stephen murda chief medical officer
sunrise hospital and medical center
and dr murder will be available for
specific medical questions
as well as two of our guest speakers dr
john redd chief medical officer the
united states department of health and
human services
office of the assistant secretary for
preparedness and response
as well as lynn hayes commander
the national disaster medical assistants
disaster medical assistance team of the
office of the assistant secretary of
preparedness and response
in the u.s department of health and
human services
before we begin today a couple of
housekeeping items for
our media visitors as many of us are in
line of sight
of our trauma bay we might have some
ambulances coming by
and i ask it just to protect the privacy
of any patients
that if ambulances do arrive that we
take a close shot to avoid
any pictures of our patients
and following today's news briefing
we're given the opportunity for
one-on-one
interviews as well as a tour interviews
with any of our
speakers and we'll also have some
digital assets
uh for event that will be available to
you
for your stories
sunrise hospital has discharged 657
covered 19 patients to date
we wish we could say that is the end
however today at sunrise hospital okay
in addition to our 736 patients
currently in-house 207
proven positive patients are receiving
care
at sunrise hospital today a record
covet 19 volume for sunrise
hospital and following the holidays
at christmas new year's the covert surge
has continued resulting in inpatients
waiting for beds in our adult emergency
department
as well as our icu's here at the
hospital
being completely full and we anticipate
that coven 19 volume
coming into sunrise hospital as well as
all of our hospitals
in our community will continue to
increase
for the weeks to come now we have a
vaccine
in place and we have vaccinated
almost 2500 members of the sunrise
hospital
family and our vaccines are becoming
and continue to become readily available
but what could we be done today
to reduce covet 19 hospitalizations
and that's where we're very very excited
with the assistance of u.s department of
health and human services
that we will open and begin
administering monoclonal antibody
therapeutic treatments at this temporary
monoclonal
antibody infusion center for coven 19
patients
this is the third federally supported
infusion clinic in the country
selected by the state of nevada to be
located
here at sunrise hospital
when physicians refer vulnerable coven
19 positive patients
requiring admission to a hospital
they will receive an aggressive
treatment plan of monoclonal antibodies
and we will reduce the overall related
hospital admissions
in the las vegas metropolitan area
this is just one more way that we can
end
the pandemic together and now i'd like
to turn
the podium over to dr john redd chief
medical officer for the u.s department
of health and human services
office of the assistant secretary for
preparedness
and response dr red
thank you very much mr slamberg good
morning everyone
my name is dr john redd i'm the chief
medical officer
of the assistant secretary for
preparedness and response also known as
asper
at the u.s department of health and
human services in washington
i'm a clinical internist a specialist in
adult medicine
and a medical epidemiologist i want to
thank
mr schlemberg and all the staff here at
sunrise
for their warm reception for their
enthusiasm
in bringing these new treatments to bear
for patients here in las vegas
and i want to thank over the entire
course of the pandemic
the efforts of the state of nevada uh to
to put us
all on the same page in what is very
clearly a
team sport which is the national
response to this pandemic
so throughout the uh the response the
federal government
state government the hhs regions we've
all remained as one
in our efforts to combat covet 19 in the
united states
today what we're talking about here in
las vegas
is a very very positive event we're
talking about
provision of care in a phase of illness
for which up until now for people with
covet 19
we've had very little to offer and
that's monoclonal antibody therapy
what i'd like you to think about is
think of this sequence of events that
happens when someone
gets coveted and then becomes ill
of course by far the best thing to do is
to prevent covet 19 in the first place
for that we have social distancing
masking hand washing and now thankfully
we have vaccine
i just got mine on monday and i would
encourage everyone
to obtain their vaccine however as we
can see
by the situation here at sunrise
we still have many many cases of covid19
many hospitalizations and both here in
southern nevada and around the country
hospital systems are suffering from an
overwhelming number of patients
so what we offer today and here at the
infusion center
is new monoclonal antibody therapy that
very specifically
targets for treatment people who are
early in their covid19 disease
these products are intended for people
with
confirmed covet 19 who have risk factors
and it's a it's a wonderful event in the
history of treatment of covid19
because previously we've had so little
to offer in this phase of illness
the antibody therapies that will be
infused here and uh
lynn hayes the commander of the team
here we'll talk about the patient
experience in a moment
the the antibody therapies that are
going to be infused here
go in over the course of an hour
the person is observed for an hour
afterward
and then they go home and here are the
numbers that are extremely favorable
especially when you
look at the heroic efforts of a of an
institution such as sunrise
against covet 19. these products can
reduce the rate of hospitalization
in people with risk factors from
approximately 15 percent
to 4 that means we can reduce the rate
of hospitalization by approximately 70
percent
the other way to look at it is that for
every 10 people
who are treated with these antibody
products you avoid one hospitalization
and that that would be wonderful so just
imagine that for every 10 people
that go through the doors here you've
avoided a hospitalization
and that's what we all want for the
country and
for the state of nevada and of course
for southern nevada and las vegas
so today i wanted to turn i'll be happy
to take questions later but
uh the commander of our dmat here lynn
hayes is going to speak about the
patient experience here at the tent and
then be very happy to take questions
thank you very much
thank you dr ed
it's an honor to be here at sunrise
hospital
as mentioned i'm the team commander for
the connecticut one
disaster medical assistance team known
as dmap
through the national disaster medical
system asper
and hhs um i am the team commander
and dmaccs are one of five specialty
teams
within ndms um
with me are ten of my teammates
we are nurses paramedics a safety
officer
pharmacist physician and emts
and we've deployed here to help the
staff
at sunrise hospital to establish the
sunrise
monoclonal antibody facility here
um behind you you will see our infusion
site
the site is actually a 40 by 40 foot
tent
it has both heat air conditioning it has
electricity as well as
a complete computer setup so we're able
to record
all of our patients records we have
eight beds
we can treat up to 32 patients per day
and each treatment takes about a half an
hour two and a half hours
so what the patient experience will be
is our patients will enter from over
here
and they will come in they'll be greeted
they'll have a quick assessment they'll
have their vital signs done
they then will be escorted to the
infusion area
where they will have their iv catheter
placed
their infusion started we will closely
monitor them
for an hour when their infusion is done
we will continue to observe and monitor
them and make sure they're feeling well
for about an hour
before they're discharged to home and
our goal
is to keep patients who qualify for this
treatment
out of the hospital sunrise similar to
almost every other hospital in the
country has limited bed capacity
the staff here have been working
tirelessly around the clock
to take care of patients and the more
people we keep out of the hospital
the better it is for everyone thank you
thank you commander hayes and dr redd
for briefing the entire community on
the benefits of the and fusion clinic
which will open up at 1pm today
we're going to open it up for some
questions however
several of you have advanced a couple of
questions
that perhaps i'll look to dr red and
commander hayes to help answer such as
some of the specifics
when when is the clinic going to be open
up
at what are the hours and how do i know
if i qualify for treatment so
maybe dr redd if you could
so our hours will be starting at eight
o'clock
um it will be by appointment
only through a patient's position
they can work with their physician to
get the information to make an
appointment
it will be from 8 am to 5 p.m
which will include the two and a half
hours for
you know patients to be seen and um dr
red do you want to talk a little bit
about the qualifications
thanks
sure thank you and i in particular would
like to direct some of my remarks at
referring physicians in the community um
because it's extremely important that
referring physicians become aware of
these products
and refer their patients in so i do want
to go over for whom
these products are intended and how they
work
so first how do these products work
the way that i view them is that they
are giving you a head start
when you have covet when any of us is
infected with the sars cov2 virus which
causes covet
we develop antibodies in our own uh
bloodstream and our own system that
that's normal
what these products do is they give you
a head start
you've got early covet 19 and through
getting an infusion here
you're getting a tremendous number of
antibodies that start fighting the kovid
19 virus right in your bloodstream
that's the way i look at them they are
intended for people who have
confirmed covid19 so that's with a test
it can be a rapid test or a pcr test
and then secondly it's intended for
people with risk factors
there are some specific risk factors but
the primary ones
are age so that's greater than or equal
to age 65.
anyone hearing this with documented cova
19 disease
who was age 65 or older is eligible i'll
pause for just a second
[Music]
secondly anyone who is 55 years of age
or over
with a cardiac or pulmonary condition
is eligible thirdly
anyone with a body mass index a bmi
which is based upon weight and height
of 35 or older is eligible
and then people of any age with certain
chronic conditions are eligible
the your physicians will know what those
conditions are
and the thing i do want to emphasize for
both physicians and patients
is that these products are approved for
up to 10 days
after onset of symptoms so the first
symptom that you get cough or headache
or fever whatever it may be
you're eligible for 10 days after that
symptom however i want to emphasize
the earlier the better so we're really
putting a big emphasis
on early identification of patients
early testing and early referral
to this center right here thank you
one one other question that uh came
forward
uh you know in advance and dr redd uh
we're hearing a lot about some of the
challenges
from the variant from the uk
maybe you could comment if this has
changed
are infusion protocols at all
yes thank you very much so the question
is in reference
to the new variant of the sars cov2
virus that's been reported from
the united kingdom and now has been
reported in the united states
that's that has been a mutation in the
rna
of the sars cov2 virus uh such mutations
are actually expected to happen
especially in viruses that are rna
viruses
happily the presence of that variant has
not changed our
protocols for this infusion at all
so although we are continuing to
look at that variant extremely closely
and follow it in the united states
it has not changed the program for here
for the therapeutics
and we would still encourage everyone
with confirmed covet 19 with risk
factors
to avail themselves of this therapeutic
we had one other question in advance and
then we'll open it up
to the media for any questions and i
think
although dr redd you know referenced it
maybe i could ask dr murda to come up
and address specifically the
referrals that coming into the infusion
center
and what other physician offices urgent
care centers
emergency rooms need to do in order to
refer a patient over to the clinic dr
berger
thank you todd and and thank you dr redd
and the team
this has been an incredible opportunity
for us and we went into a
motion over a week to stand this up
because we knew every day
as the kovic vaccinate vaccine
was being rolled out we knew that we
also had to get those
people that weren't fortunate to get the
vaccine before they became
infected so what we're asking is once a
patient is identified
by a physician or an urgent care that we
have a number that we will be providing
to for the individual to once they've
met the screening criteria
to call that number have the patient
call the number they will be scheduling
an appointment
we're running four blocks of uh
time-lapse
timelines at eight o'clock eleven
o'clock two o'clock and five o'clock
where we'll bring in eight patients and
treat them uh so the goal is to call
that
number i don't have it in front of me
but we'll get it to you make that
appointment
arrive 15 minutes before stay in your
car and then we don't want our
covet positive patients out and about
walking around
we want them to stay in isolated come in
as we ask them to
and then treat them so that's the plan
thank you
now we will open it up to any questions
that the media will have and then
i will help facilitate the answers um
okay i'll ask dr murder dr redd
to uh answer the question just about the
frequency of the treatment
i'm sorry mary if you don't mind could
you repeat the question please
oh yeah yes so yeah thank you very much
so
um these treatments are a single
infusion
so it's it's one time and
that's part of what makes them so
convenient and so exciting
so again i want to emphasize the the key
features are
early reporting to your physician of
symptoms
early testing and then rapid referral
right here we've set up a very
convenient system
and it's a it's a one-time deal
thank you
so with one hour of infusion we reduce
hospitalizations
here in las vegas by 70 for for cova for
those patients who meet criteria
other questions
what type of follow-up treatment is
involved and
will the patient incur any cost okay
dr murder maybe you could answer that
question as to what other follow-up
treatments
that might be necessary uh you know
following the
uh following the infusion and then is
there any cost
well thank you thank you for that
question any follow-up treatments are
the answer is there aren't any uh once
you have that infusion we'll
return you to your home where you will
continue to monitor your symptoms
if your symptoms unfortunately were to
progress then the recommendation would
be getting
get a hold of your physician for
follow-up for further therapy
so there is no additional thank you
and the cost is there any coffin
possible okay
no the federal government has provided
the
the team and provided the medication so
at this time there is absolutely no cost
to anyone getting this infusion
let me answer i'll be happy to answer
that question too about these exciting
here in las vegas
and but but first in reference to how
the products have been made available
is similar to vaccine which you all have
heard about
up the uh program called operation warp
speed has developed and then procured
vaccine and therapeutics and
in the case of vaccine and the new
therapeutics
the cost to the person is zero these
products
have been procured by the united states
government
on behalf of all americans and in
pursuit
of treatment of people all across the
united states i want to say this again
very clearly these medications
as well as vaccine they're meant for
everyone across the united states
we're all in this together this has been
a group effort
we did this on behalf of the people of
the united states
for human beings all around the united
states so i just really want to
emphasize
that and then in terms of of why this
site
well a lot of it actually has to do with
a combination
of a very willing partner and i again
want to commence sunrise for their
flexibility and i want to say something
else that you all really should be proud
of
i know that uh las vegas has been
through difficult times together
including right here at this very
hospital and i really want to commend
their spirit
people here have been working on this
pandemic for a year
yet despite that the staff here are
flexible
willing to take on a new treatment and
looking forward
to try to change the the direction of
covet-19 infection in southern nevada
and i
i can't say enough about them i really
commend the staff here so it's a
combination of need
a willing site and availability
we'll open it up to any other questions
before we do a tour and then we'll have
members of the team here also available
for any
individual interviews